Ever wondered what secrets PO pros know
that you don't? I'm going to expose them
in this video. Everything from more
effective training to the best things to
focus on. I am going to give you the
inside scoop.
[music]
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, I'm exposing
five tips of the poi professionals that
you could benefit from. But before we
dive in, I just want to give a quick
shout out to the friends in the channel.
Big thanks to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyroer, Light
Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible. You
can learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
here video. Any way you look at it,
learning poi is a challenge. But for
those of us who've gone through the
process and are several years, if not
decades later, there are some inside
baseball tips that I can offer that are
going to help you get to where I got a
lot faster. Now, in terms of the
specifics, a lot is going to depend upon
your own particular flow journey and
what your goals are. But by and large,
I'm pretty sure that I can guarantee you
each of every one of these five tips is
going to help you get there. Starting
with tip number [music] one, develop
beat control early. So beat control is
something that I've been harping on now
for a long, long time. And it's one of
the easiest ways that I can tell the
difference between people who have
trained themselves versus people who've
actually gone through and learned from
other people. The long and short of it
is is that in a lot of cases when people
learn their different tricks peacemeal,
they tend to learn them in such a way
that they become habituated to spinning
the po at a constant rate. This really
comes across when they say try to
control how many reps they do of a given
trick or when they open up into
performing bigger moves like flowers.
The antidote to this is to develop beat
control as soon as possible. Alien John
once explained this to me as such.
Without beat control, the poi is
basically in control of when the hand
moves and when it doesn't. But when you
do develop beat control, your hand is
what's in control of the movement of the
poi. And you get to decide how many
beats the poi performs as the hand is
moving around to different places. This
gives you much more control and it makes
your spinning so much more refined. It's
also absolutely essential for getting
down all intermediate and advanced level
tricks. And I did an entire month's
worth of drills on how to develop beat
control on my Patreon. So, I'm going to
go ahead and link to those videos down
in the description for those of you who
are up for taking on this challenge. Tip
number two, practice each trick going
both directions. So, this is definitely
going to be a tip that a lot of the pros
out there are going to roll their eyes
and say, "Well, duh." But the thing is,
I have worked with a lot of beginners,
and you'd be shocked how many of them do
not go through this step. Basically, any
and all PO tricks that involve the PO
spinning come with two possible
direction variations. You can spin
forward or reverse, clockwise or
counterclockwise. You can spin an inward
butterfly or an outward butterfly. It
totally depends upon what the specific
class of trick is. But each and every
one will have two variants. And as soon
as you learn one of them, make sure that
you learn the other. This may be a huge
challenge, but in the grand scheme of
things, it's really going to help out
your spinning. Not the least of which
because when you're, say, playing around
with transitions later on, you're going
to have access to any and all versions
of one trick as you try to get to
another. Plus, which this is a great
thing to do when you reach those dreaded
plateaus rather than wondering what is
the next trick to learn. The answer is
really probably the tricks you learned
before, but just going the opposite
direction. And having the capacity to do
them in any direction is going to open
up so many more possibilities for you in
the future. I definitely put off this
step for way too long. Many years into
my career, I had to go back and relearn
a bunch of beginner and intermediate
tricks going the opposite directions of
the ones that I had originally learned
them in. It was a long and painstaking
process. And quite frankly, if I had
just done it this way to begin with, I
would have had a much easier road. So,
learn from my mistakes. Tip number
three, focus on technique over tricks.
So, this one is a really hard one
because a lot of us get focused on
tricks as kind of being a bit of a
benchmark that we're progressing with
poi. If we get harder and harder tricks,
the logic follows that we are getting
better and better at poi, right? Well,
yes and no. Because in a lot of cases,
you can work on a particular trick for
months at a time and make no progress.
But if you work on specific underlying
techniques that are shared by a bunch of
different tricks, all of a sudden you're
going to find that a number of different
things become a lot easier as a result.
So this involves getting down everything
from linear isolations and linear
extensions to being able to drill your
plane control both with your arms
crossed as well as your hands behind
your back and thus getting access to all
the different tricks that require all of
these different techniques. Really, if
you focus on what the underlying
techniques are rather than the tricks
that make use of those techniques, you
get access to way more things overall,
and you will undoubtedly find more uses
for them in the future, too. To say
nothing of the fact that frequently when
we learn specific tricks, we also forget
the techniques we had to go through in
order to learn them. For example, you
probably had to learn two beat weaves in
order to get to three beat weaves, but
once you've been doing three beat weaves
for a year, you've forgotten how to do
the two beat. And the two beat is really
necessary for a variety of different
body tracers and other realbased tricks.
So make sure that they never fall out of
rotation and is going to save you a lot
of time and stress. Want to know which
specific techniques are good to focus on
if you want to get the maximum benefit
out of your PO spinning? I have done a
whole series of said videos that I will
link to a playlist of down in the
description as well as up in the cards.
Check it out. Tip number four, drill
transition tools. [music]
So, aside from the question of which
trick I should learn next, the question
of how to transition between tricks is
one that comes up surprisingly often and
surprisingly early in most people's flow
journeys. After all, learning the tricks
makes us feel really accomplished. But
when it comes to actually performing
them for other people or, you know,
being able to just sit around and flow,
well, we still need to get between those
different tricks. So, how exactly do we
do it? And quite frankly, the answer is
that you need to be drilling transition
tools at least as much as you're
drilling the actual tricks that go back
and forth between them. Namely, you need
to drill your stalls. You need to drill
your pendulums and a variety of other
different transition tools as well. Do
yourself a favor and early on drill
changing timing and direction with
either pendulums or stalls or both.
You'll be surprised just how far this
simple little exercise will actually get
you in terms of moving back and forth
between a variety of different PO
tricks. Now, before I share with you my
final tip of the PO pros, I do have just
a small favor to ask. If you've come
this far, it likely means that you have
an interest in PO spinning and
specifically learning how to get further
with it. And if that's the case, well,
my channel is chock full of those
videos. If you could make sure to
subscribe to my channel, it'll ensure
that you see my latest videos as they
get posted and you get a leg up on that
journey. Thank you in advance. And now
my number one tip from the PO pros is
tip number one. Slow the down. So I will
be the first to admit this is a really
difficult tip especially for beginners.
When you're first starting out you're
really anxious, you're really excited
and it can be really really really
challenging to slow things down. Not the
least of which because it's really
exciting to go fast and it tends to make
an audience really excited too. But the
thing is, there are so many poi
techniques that you can only perform if
you slow things down. When you're
learning, it really helps to be able to
see what you're going to do before you
do it. And the faster you spin, the more
challenging that becomes. In some ways,
you can think of this as being related
to beat control in that it is more of a
conscious amount of control over
spinning the poi. I've known tons of
people who walk into my workshops who
can spin really, really fast, but the
moment that I ask them to make specific
choices with their poi, they're unable
to. And in some cases, I have to retach
them a trick that they thought they
learned years ago. And also, just on an
aesthetic level, being able to spin more
slowly is a really powerful tool to have
in your back pocket because then if you
can choose whether you're spinning fast
or spinning slow, it becomes a really
dynamic performance tool. in the right
hands. This can be even more powerful to
the audience than just being able to
spin fast. It's helpful for learning.
It's helpful for performance. And more
than anything else, it will help you to
go further. So, please do slow down and
see how the worlds open up for you as a
result. Cool. So, those were my top five
tips. Were there any that were a
surprise to you? Were there any that you
think I left off the list? Please leave
me a comment and let me know. Also, be
sure to share this video so other people
can find it. And of course, it'll help
my channel grow. Thanks in advance.
[music]
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you all so much
for supporting my channel, my work, and
my mission. And if you out there
watching would like to get your name in
the credits or access to a whole host of
other awesome rewards, you can do that
by heading over to my Patreon at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo
and signing up. I'll leave a link to it
down in the description as well as up in
the cards. Please help me out in my
mission of bringing po spinning and flow
arts to the whole wide world. Thank you
in advance. If you'd like to learn more
about slowing down your spinning, I did
an entire video on that topic that I'll
go ahead and link to up here on screen
as well as down in the description.
Thank you so much for watching. Make
sure to get out and flow yourselves
today. And I'll see you with a new video
real soon. Take care now.
>> [music]